So now let's go back to the things that we need
to operate a network. So we need a way to encode
and interpret messages. So we saw that we can encode any
message that we want in bits. And then we can encode the
bits on the wire. How that encoding actually works is pretty
complicated, it's not something that we're going to talk about in this class,
but there are lots of different ways to do it. But
we're figuring out ways for each zero and one to encode that
as something that we send along a wire, or it could be
wireless. What we haven't talked about, which we're, we are going to talk
about soon, is what these high level messages are. Right? We need
ways to send messages that can be interpreted and understood at the
other side. And so, what we'll talk about next is how that
works on the internet. As far as the way to route messages.
For the internet, all of the routers along that path. Well, a
message comes in. It has a desination. The routers have to figure
out the next destination to go to. And that's also quite a
challenging problem. It's something we're not
going to get into more detail in this
class. But you can imagine different ways you might do this. A router
might have a table that says, well, if you're in California and you
want to send a message to Boston, you should first send it to
Nevada, because that's going in the right direction. That's not quite the way
things work, because we saw that there was actually just one message. That
really, what you want to do is send it to San Jose, we've got
a big strong pipe that goes all the way to Boston.
Finally you need ways to decide who gets resources. And on
our Greek network we assume that the general could decide. The
internet is much more of a wild west in that in
the internet there aren't any real rules for who gets resources.
Everywhere along the network gets to decide on it's own how
to do that. And what we really get on the Internet
is just what we call best effort service. If your message
needs to go over the same link as some other message, the
router can only send one message at a time. It's up to the
router to decide what to do. There are different policies that different routers
follow. There's no general rule that is enforced on the whole internet. And
this means that sometimes your packet might just get dropped. There's no
guarantee, when you send a message on the internet, that it actually gets
to where you want it to. So we're not going to talk more about
these two in this class. I'll encourage you to take a future networking
class that will get into those details. We are going to talk
a little bit about how the messages work for the web.